hey I was going for us my name is Beth
today we are going to visit my
girlfriend my real real girlfriend I
know you think I did Marzia but this was
my first love
Evy
Evy how are you
EB is mine too stupid as ever
how are you honey I'm not a honey you
see everything please cm thing yes do
you have consciousness yes she goes with
our philosophy again then you're inhuman
no I'm Abby what are you I just said I'm
a pretty Evie I love you baby Emma I
love you too baby
I love you too baby you love me too a
baby
don't wake leg when you say that you
[ __ ] pedophile
do you know Naruto
yes I lived with him holy [ __ ] what's he
like here's me what contender for [ __ ]
sake he smites evil with his Rasengan
have you offered your booty to someone
else only you have you brushed yours yes
brushed first ahead wink again okay
knock knock who's there
Naruto Naruto who Naruto King L Naruto
Dell hon I'm [ __ ] does that mean
can I eat your eyebrows no he's a person
oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry I didn't know that
what about your eyelids can I eat those
nothing about my eyes but they look so
tasty
why did the chicken cross the road don't
know to get to the other side oh my god
she there's no stop who's there
Nikhil old lady little old lady who I
didn't know you could yodel
oh you'll old lady old lady oh well you
know what I don't I don't know why I'm
new room do you want to go on a date
oh well right now rats yes way to enemy
Expo hmm which anime is my favorite what
Naruto obviously Noriko is not animal
hero you're right I'm sorry
how old are you sorry you're too old for
me